thanks for the introduction so I'm
Jordan and this is joint work with Sasha
and we're starting at the basics doing
some of the simplest SandForce problems
you could do is working with binary data
and hypothesis tests now it turns out
that it's still quite a challenge with
differential privacy so there's been a
good amount of previous literature on
hypothesis testing and differential
privacy I sort of started with boo and
slash kovitch binomial data tests and
that's sort of the jumping-off point for
our research is going back to these
simple problem and working with it in a
very theoretical framework so there's
been lots of other hypothesis testing
works on different types of data such as
contingency tables normal data linear
regression recently there's been a real
interesting paper by canonical and
simple.i policies which we'll hear about
in just a moment and then there's also
been some interesting work on her
asymptotic tests by long at all so the
structure of the stock our motivation is
to work out uniformly most powerful test
s-- so this is in classical statistics
the gold standard of the hypothesis test
said that we'd like to find I'll define
it later and these are really
fundamental in classical statistics
they're closely related to efficiency
likelihood inference and we'll see how
we can use these hypothesis tests to
produce confidence intervals as well so
our initial goal is to develop
hypothesis test and p-values working
with binary data under differential
privacy so some of the highlights of our
contributions so we're going to produce
the first um key tests under the
framework of differential privacy and
this is for bernoulli data along the way
we develop a new distribution which we
call the two-lap distribution for
truncated uniform lipgloss and this
extends the staircase and discrete
Lacroix's distributions also known as
the geometric distribution
maybe shows our tests can be written in
terms of this distribution that we've
developed from this we can derive
p-values that agree with our tests we
show that as we claim in our proofs that
this does outperform other tests in the
literature and then we show how we can
take our p-values to produce confidence
intervals that also have optimal
properties so the notion of differential
privacy that we're working under is
epsilon Delta D P so we're going to
consider our database to be a vector of
entries each entries from one individual
where we're assuming that n is fixed and
known and so we're just going to be
swapping one entry in this list we think
of a mechanism as a set of probability
measures and so we are given our
database we're drawing from some
distribution and so different surprises
says when I change let's see okay so if
I change one entry of X then I want this
distribution to only change by a small
amount
and so they usually want the etruscans
to be similar
so about hypothesis testing so generally
a test is trying to determine the value
of a parameter that we don't know what
it is so we're trying to learn about
theta and it lives in some parameter
space capital theta we're trying to
decide whether it lives in theta 0 or
theta 1 which are disjoint subsets of
big theta so we call theta 0 the null
set so this is sort of your assumption
beforehand and then the alternative
would be oh we thought something really
interesting this is not what we expected
we could write a paper about it and so
we're going to model a test as a map
from the set of databases to 0 1 where
this value in 0 1 represents the
probability of rejecting so that's where
we're going to incorporate our
randomness for a differential privacy is
in this random decision of whether we're
going to accept or reject so typically
in classical statistics we have
deterministic tests and so if this is
the rectangle is our parameter space
then we might have at some cutoff points
we would go from never rejecting to
always rejecting oh sorry I misspoke so
this is the this is the space of
databases so for some databases you
would never reject in some databases you
would always reject but because we need
to incorporate randomness instead we
have some gradient where there's always
a small probability of rejecting and
that probably increases as we move to
the right and so the actual output would
be we would flip the coin with
probability feet and then that will
output either accept or reject two more
concepts of hypothesis tests we have the
size also knows the type 1 error and
this is the probability of accidentally
rejecting when the null was actually
true so typically we limit the size to a
predetermined value such as 0.05 or you
could do something smaller and so this
is a hard threshold that we're going to
keep fixed
and then given that we've limited the
type 1 error we want to have the most
powerful test possible which means that
when the alternative is true we want to
be able to reject as much as possible
and so we say the power at some value
theta is the probability rejecting when
we're getting together from that forever
value okay so we're gonna look at test
speed that size my differential privacy
we're going to fix the size and try to
optimize the power so in particular we
are working with binary data so each
person tells us a 0 or 1 and we've got
this vector of zeros and ones we're
gonna model these as independent
bernoulliís and so we're assuming there
is some underlying proportion theta that
we're trying to infer we have a
technical lemma that says that even in
differential privacy we can get away by
just recording the number of ones so we
just have to work with X now and X is
now distribute as binomial which leads
to the title of the talk for working
with this binomial distribution from now
on
and so the test that we're looking at
for the moment we're just going to
release the decision accept or reject
that's the only output of our mechanism
later we'll see if we can do more than
that and these two decisions accept or
reject have probability fee and 1 minus
V so in the setting of differential
privacy we are our notion is in terms of
the probability of all possible outputs
and all possible adjacent databases but
because our problem is so simple it
turns out we can actually write down all
of these inequalities in terms of our
function fee so the only outputs of
interest the only sense be of interest
are reject or accept and these have
probabilities P and 1 minus P so we can
replace all the P of B's with the other
fee of X or P 1 X minus 1 I probably
could do X and X plus 1 but you can
rearrange it the way you so to get this
and then the right so the only adjacent
databases that knows the value of x
increases or decreases by one and so we
can take all these abstracts
inequalities and write down these for n
inequalities here now it's going to be
convenient later to arrange Li as in a
slightly different way and so we're
going to show that or in write in a way
so that we can define fee recursively so
if I take fee of 0 given then I have two
upper bounds and two lower bounds on fee
of 1 and so I can relate BX in terms of
px minus 1 and so I could I could just
be 0 and then I have a range of values I
can pick for P 1 and then I have a new
range for P 2 and as long as I satisfy
these inequalities as I go along
once I have picked all 0 through n then
that thing is still differentially
private so we're going to look at
they're gonna study test speed that
satisfy all these inequalities which is
equivalent to satisfying differential
privacy so we'll denote that set by a
fancy D we'll keep track of the
epsilon-delta and the end
okay so our goal here are our initial
goal is to determine the most powerful
test among these differentially private
test B so we're looking all over the
sets the things that satisfy those
inequalities we're fixing the size out
this is the type 1 error and the
hypothesis that we're gonna test for the
moment is going to be the null is that
pain is less than some value and the
alternative is that it's actually larger
than the value so perhaps we're
collecting data on whether you have a
disease or not and it's been previously
believed that the prevalence of diseases
some amount or less and we're saying oh
no there's actually an epidemic so we we
say we've worn the alarm and say that
actually it's higher than we thought in
which case we reject so the way we're
going to build this
so first we'll think back to classical
statistics there's one of the first
problems that you would learn about in
sistex in Printz class and you learn
that you're supposed to use the name and
Pearson lemma to figure out the optimal
test and whatever Pearson lemma says is
that you go along and at low values of X
we have no evidence that we should
reject high values of X you have a lot
of evidence and so there's a point where
you jump from 0 to 1 and maybe there's a
fuzzy point in the middle but there's
essentially this hard line where we go
from never rejecting to always rejecting
and never Pearson is sort of a greedy
solution which ends up being optimal so
we can't do the same thing because
adjunct from 0 to 1 would violate the
upper bound that we have here we're only
allowed to jump by some amount so let's
take the spirit of near-end Pearson
lemma where we want to be greedy but
we're going to do it one step at a time
so we'll take fee of zero as something
predetermined I don't know how to choose
it yet and now I'm gonna have to upper
bounds for a fee of 1 I'm gonna take the
smallest meaning the largest valid value
of fee of 1 and so here once I have
chosen fee two I see that I have these
to over balance given by these two
equations and so I'm just going to go
along picking the largest value I'm
allowed to while still achieving
differential privacy so it's a sort of
an intuitive solution and it turns out
the intuition is correct and using a
same a similar proof as neyman-pearson
you can show that this is in fact the
ump tests but it's not super satisfying
because it's sort of ad hoc we're going
one by one it'd be nice to have a closed
form solution of this test so then we
had an insights that this test fee it's
an increasing function on an increasing
from left to right and it takes -
between zero and one so it's actually
the CDF of some random variable meaning
the cumulative distribution function so
there's some just some random variable
that corresponds to this increasing
function it turns out that we figured
out what it is and we call it the
two-lap distribution so with parameters
related to epsilon and delta we're able
to write the optimal test in terms of
the cdf of this distribution so what is
this chillout distribution we found so i
intuitive way to understand it is you
could take a discrete laplace this is
the same as the geometric mechanism and
a uniform between minus 1/2 and 1/2 and
you add them together along with the
center which is a constant and then what
you get is this staircase type
distribution it's exactly it's exactly
the staircase but what we do is to get
the Delta in the epsilon Delta we chop
off the tails at certain quantiles
where Q was related to epsilon and Delta
and so we call it the truncated uniform
Laplace because that's how you
constructors and so what this gives us I
give this a few really nice things first
of all it gives us a close form for this
ump test that's nice
but it also turns out that we're able to
get p-values by using this distribution
so how is that well it turns out that we
can write our test fee as a post
processing of X plus a noise value from
this to lot distribution so fee is the
CDF of the tool app evaluated at X the
CDF is exactly just the probability that
X is less than and rearranging this a
little bit we see that we can release X
+ n where n is from 2 up and then just
evaluate the CD at the this probability
afterwards and to remind you what a
p-value is is if you have a bunch of
hypothesis tests at different sizes
alpha the p-value is the smallest alpha
such that we would output reject so you
could do a search for your binary search
you could figure out what's the smallest
value of alpha that you can get away
with rejecting that would be the p-value
but it turns out there's an even more
efficient way to go about this for this
problem and so if we have our data X we
then produce our noisy summary statistic
where we take X we add a two-lap so we
have this year Z given X is our summary
statistic so first of all Z does satisfy
Absalon Delta differential privacy and
then an easy way to compute it is in
terms of the PMF of the binomial down
here and the CDF of the two-lap you take
an inner product it's as easy as that
that we're able to compute the p-values
so these p-values satisfy difference of
privacy because they're post-processing
Z and they agree with our um P tests
that we developed earlier so an
important observation here we set out to
only release accept or reject and at the
same level of privacy we found that
actually we are able to release the
summary statistic and produce p-values
which we never intended to be able to do
so so that's quite nice and it turns out
that we're able to get even more out of
this which we'll see going on first just
a sanity check
so we claim in the theorem that this was
the most powerful test well so in boo
and sloths kovitch they gave a normal
approximation test and where it's going
to see that in fact we are able to get
higher power than their test we're all
we're still bound above by the not in
private case and more interestingly we
have exact type 1 error up two numerical
inaccuracies but the normal
approximation has very type 1 error
because it is an approximation to the
test
okay so what else can we do
so the next thing we'd like to do is
two-sided tests so we were working at
one side of hypotheses where we said the
null was Thetas less than something and
the alternative was that thatõs bigger
well those are common to look at things
like testing theta is equal to theta 0
versus not so so the first thing is we
know in classical statistics that there
is no uniformly most powerful test in
this setting and the problem is that you
could take the most powerful right sided
test and the most powerful left side
test and they would dominate in
different regions so sort of the space
of office is too large
there is no optimal thing and so we need
to reduce the search space and what's
commonly done in classical statistics is
to impose the condition of unbiasness so
guys this is not the same quite the same
thing as you might think for Floyd
estimates the idea of an unbiased tests
is now we want to make sure that under
the null the probability rejecting is
always smaller than anything in the
alternative so any unbiased test seems
fairly reasonable by imposing this
condition there are still good tests
that are ruled out by this it might be
that it dips slightly below in the
alternative space and we're missing out
on those but in classical statistics
this is what's commonly done and so by
imposing this we're now able to find the
ump unbiased test right so some biases
the idea is that we want to be rejecting
more often in the alternative than the
null no matter which value is we take
from the alternative ordinal so using a
similar construction we're able to get a
U of P unbiased alpha test among our DP
tests and the argument is similar so
without privacy we could imagine I don't
have an image but imagine we have our
set of X's so for large X's or small X's
we would eventually reject with
certainty and if it's moderate near the
the null that we wouldn't reject so the
idea here is that we're gonna have some
Center K and then we want to increase as
much as possible in both directions and
that's what we see here so there's some
K which we'll have to figure out what it
is and then we're going to be a two-lap
CDF on either side of it where we're
increasing as much as possible subject
to the DP constraints and so we can
write in this form as a piecewise where
each evaluation is the CDF of the tool
app and then we have a few more
conditions we need to make sure so the
second condition is just checking that
it is size alpha so that's quite
standard and this other one is going to
impose the unbiasness so this condition
you'll see if you read a textbook in
classical statistics so it's basically
checking with the correlation or the
covariance between X and fee of X is
zero
and it turns out that that is equivalent
in this setting to check in for
unbiasness as we defined it so if you
could find your K and M such that these
two equations hold then it is the ump
test and we can show that there is
always a solution so it's just a matter
of a finance so as I said this is what
these tests look like so they're
centered that's okay and then they
increase on both sides and we're going
as the epsilon is increasing we get
closer to the jump functions that you
would get without privacy so without
privacy we would just be zero in the
middle here and that one outside and so
we're converging to that as the privacy
goes or less privacy higher Epsilon
so this unbiased test is also a function
of the tulip and so theoretically you
could compute the p-values but the
problem here is that the K and M depend
on alpha so it's sort of a pain to do
that minimization problem there isn't a
nice closed form for the p-values like
there was in the one-sided case but
we're able to get something quite close
so we notice that K although it depends
on alpha as the sample size increases K
gets very close to end theta zero so the
center here where we change sides is
close to the mean of the binomial and as
the sample size increases that becomes a
converges to that and so what we could
do is we could just choose K is n theta
0 and still so that would eliminate this
constraint and then we would still set
the size as alpha and that's what we do
here that we're able to get the p-value
from that construction and so it's still
a valid p-value meaning that the
corresponding test has the exact size
it's just that we're giving up on the
unbiasness and we're just asymptotically
unbiased instead of exactly unbiased so
and we'll see in the simulation in a
second that it's a really close
approximation so here we have a
simulation so there's four curves here
so what are the four curves so we have
the one-sided tests in green and blue so
this is not the one you want to pick
because this one is testing so the null
is that beta is to the right of the
value and so we get less and less
evidence as we observe things to the
right the left one would be the most
powerful test for testing that theta is
less than it versus the right so that's
an upper bound for any two-sided test
and then the two curves here and red and
purple are the in red is the ump
unbiased and the purple is our
approximation and this is for n is 30 so
as the Sam
increases that gets only closer and this
is just a zoomed in version around zero
two point two to see what's happening
with the curves and we see that the
purple the approximate test is just a
slight shift of the red
um p.m. biased one okay any questions so
far
okay hopefully I haven't lost everyone
so the last part of the talk is
discussing how we can turn these tests
which is we've just been focused on
hypothesis and p-values and showing how
we can leverage those to produce
confidence intervals so comments
interval is a pair of random variables
so although they depend on the data X
we're also going since that a and B have
additional randomness for differential
privacy and a common sterilized coverage
gamma if under the true value theta the
probably that we contain theta is at
least gamma so this is like what
business was talking about earlier we
want to make sure that these are sort of
valid or honest comments intervals so
we're going to cyst that this
probability holds strictly and the way
we're going to go from p-values to
comments intervals is by this fact that
if you have a p-value where the null is
theta is Theta 0 it doesn't actually
matter what the alternative is you can
always produce a confidence that by
taking all the theta zeroes that you
failed to reject so the p-value is
larger than alpha then we didn't reject
it so those are sort of the plausible
values of theta and we'll keep all those
and they could have a very funky shape
but if you pick next p-values you get
usually one-sided or two-sided
confidence intervals and so we already
have differentiate priority values so we
can post process those to get different
private comments intervals
well be nice to have an optimality
criteria so we call these uniformly most
accurate confidence intervals so we
choose a coverage and we're going to
hold that fixed and then what's what
does this concept mean so under a true
theta and a full state of zero we want
that the problem that we're covering the
false value to be smaller meaning that
on average this one's going to be a
smaller interval because capturing these
incorrect Thetas less often than the
other the C prime is so this might seem
a little contrived because it is so this
is designed to be at 1:1 correspondence
with the uniformly most powerful test
but it does tend to produce the thing we
want which is smaller confidence
intervals but it doesn't do it in a very
direct manner but because of that
correspondence between ump tests and you
have made comments intervals we're able
to show that taking our one-sided
p-values and produced in the comments
interval gives us the DP um a common
interval with exact coverage cities are
the lower bounds instead of a two-sided
interval yeah what's the definition
what's the distribution again the Tulip
it's so it's a geometric distribution
plus a uniform from minus 1/2 to 1/2 and
then you might chop off the tails dude
hang on Delta yeah
and so yeah I guess I'm a little
confused
I mean you does the uniform - one half
one half do anything so it doesn't do
anything for privacy because we could
basically round it off and get back what
you would have but from just adding the
geometric right so it's like a
post-processing yeah so it's sort of we
had to make a decision where to add in
this either have additional randomness
in the fee or to put the noise into the
summary and either one works just fine
we just found it was easier to sort of
write it up in this manner any other
questions
okay so that was our one side of coms
intervals so what about two sided well
again the space is too large so we can't
get um a two sided comics intervals we
need to restrict to a smaller set well
just like their unbiased tests we're
going to make a concept run by sconce
intervals again this is sort was done in
classical statistics literature and
unbiasness means that the probability of
covering a different parameter value is
always smaller than probably covering
the true parameter value so again it's
sort of a reasonable thing to assume but
maybe not the first thing you'd think of
so then this ugly thing is the p-value
of our um PM bias test so it's literally
the smallest p-value such that the
corresponding test statistic is larger
than the corresponding threshold and K
and M as I mentioned earlier do depend
on alpha so this is sort of a pain to
compute but it does have the property
one so it's the DP um am biased s--
comments interval but in practice I
don't think it's worth computing this
rather we could take our asymptotically
unbiased test for which we have easy to
compute p values and move it and birth
that she gets an approximately unbiased
two-sided confidence interval so here
I guess I'm a little surprised that the
K depends on out but yeah I mean so if I
understand correctly your Z is the is a
noisy
yeah noise I mean the noise I mean and
now you're looking at again are the the
setting is you're trying to distinguish
theta0 from like na na so yeah I'm not
zero right and it's not the case that
setting like K to be whatever and
painted 0 would be the natural thing
that's not it's not unbiased so here's
here's a picture
maybe if 8 is a half then that's exactly
right
but if theta is not a half then so let's
so here's 0 and 1 and let's put theta
over here maybe that's yeah let's say
this is the picture of X's so the
binomial looks kind of like a normal
except it has a much longer tail on one
side and so and then the tests look like
things like this or new shapes and
different alphas will give different
shapes and we want to choose the center
where to place this such that the
covariance is 0 but the different shapes
might require to put it here versus
slightly to the left or slowly to the
right and so it's all about this
unbiasness but since the embrace and
vice is really crucial by taking it to
be n theta 0 you get a good solution use
can prove the same sort of things about
it
any other questions
okay I think that's the end so some
highlights so in the initial part of the
talk where we were developing our
hypothesis tests some of the sizes the
first result to give exactly ump tests
in the differential privacy framework we
developed this new distribution it's
sort of an extension of the staircase
distribution but it has this truncation
for epsilon Delta and the idea of
viewing the hypothesis testing and
difference of privacy in terms of the
fee function these linear constraints
provides a nice perspective you could
even view it as a linear programming
problem for simple hypotheses there are
limitations so the bernoulli's situation
is incredibly nice and it's unreasonable
to expect things to work out so nicely
other places particularly these linear
constraints don't help if you have
continuous or complicated data the name
of Pearson argument might not extend and
then kind of all based on this Renner
and Justin the scene so they they argue
that this sort of uniformly optimal
property that we're driving here is
inherent to the binary situation and so
these U and P tests likely are not going
to exist in general scenarios and then
based off of our hypothesis ting
framework we we did get coms intervals
p-values and all the way to talk about
it there's an idea called a confidence
distribution which is sort of the
frequentist version of a posterior
distribution would be happy to chat
about that afterwards if you're curious
some references and an early version of
this based on just the one-sided tests
was published in nips twenty eighteen
and a full version of the talk is on the
archive so thank you for your time
[Applause]
any questions for Jordan yeah this is
awesome
we have something that works for them
and it was 30 yeah I guess I guess a
natural question is that you also
mention this in the limitations but I'm
I'm still wondering like from the
statistic class that I learned all this
um PN the stuff they generically extend
to estimating parameters and
constructing tests for exponential
family images but this is a much more
restricted setting and what are the
things as you have in mind to relax a
ump definition you can talk about this
kind of stronger optimality guarantees
and just being a minimax
I mean getting exact minimax today for
more general problems is interesting
problem yourself and I think is still
open but what are the things that are
related to UMP that you can talk about
that's a good question so last summer I
was working with Sileo and we were
trying to do difference of binomials and
we're looking at that testing problem so
naively I thought that it would be a
simple corollary of what we're doing
here it turns out that everything breaks
right away and in fact we'd my first
week we just simulations show that there
is no UMP unbiased test for that so yeah
we were sort of exploring minimax
concepts or other other things we didn't
really come up with a good answer but we
started thinking about in terms of
sample complexity as people do but we're
still insisting on the exact size and
trying to get the the power so I'm not
sure if there's a good answer right now
how to extend these concepts of U and P
when they're when there isn't one but I
think that's a worthwhile thing to look
into
oh I was just going to point out a
similarity to an older paper gauche
rough cartons and getting the plastic
where they did something again looking
at binary data using linear programming
to come up with an optimal like a class
of algorithms and they gave this room a
class of problems that for which they
argue that post-processing the geometric
right and so it just is just like the
first part where you the explain to how
you derive based on those linear
constraints probabilities felt very
similar to that and I don't got maybe
some of the epsilon0 some of the results
might there's sounds like there's a fair
amount of overlap hmm maybe not no not
completely
you want to mention some extensions of
the medium desk for the media them
together
oh sure so there's a bit more that we
left out of the talk so there are some
distribution free hypothesis tests that
you can do on continuous data that have
binomial test statistics so one is the
sign test any other is the median test
so the idea is for the let's say the
sign test if we have paired data paired
continuous data we want to test if the
median say after treatment is higher
than before treatment you take all the
differences and then you count how many
of them are positive and then this is
the counts and so it's binomial and so
you can apply these procedures so it's
not going to be optimal in terms of all
continuous hypothesis test for the
problem but in terms of the sign test it
would be the best implement DP
implantation of that and there's another
one for the median test where they're
not paired but you have a before and
after sort of treatment to populations
then you're looking at the difference
you can do a similar thing
video they start